a lot of functions can look really ugly
and be hard to work with on the other
hand there are some truly lovely
functions that have wonderful properties
what's amazing though is that some of
these beautiful functions can actually
approximate many other functions even
ones that looked very bad today we'll
look at an example of this kind of thing
it's called the Fourier series okay
let's start by considering all the
functions that you can draw on a line
between negative L and L so what do our
nice functions look like I can make them
like this first draw a dot at zero and
then dots at the endpoints now connect
them like this you might recognize this
as a sine function then for the next one
put down the original dots and now
divide these sections into two and join
the dots for the next one you divide
this into three these are both sine
functions as well keep repeating the
process and now we've made an infinite
number of nice functions but wait let's
make some more take all of our previous
ones and shift them over so that their
first peak is now in the middle these
are all cos functions one last function
which seems like an odd Bowl is the flat
constant function and now finally we
have all the nice functions we're going
to work with you might be wondering what
exactly is so nice about these functions
well I won't say too much about it here
besides noting that they're periodic and
infinitely differentiable instead I'll
put some links in the description about
their usefulness and in the next next
video I'll explain why they're super
important in quantum mechanics okay so
back to our functions there are an
infinite number of them but it's obvious
that they're only a tiny fraction of all
possible functions it only starts to get
interesting though when we start
combining them in a special way called a
linear combination this is how you
create a linear combination pick some of
the nice functions and now multiply each
of these functions by a number this has
the effect of stretching or compressing
each of them then add these functions
together for the rest of the video we're
only going to beacon
combining the functions in this kind of
way we work for example think about
multiplying functions anyway as you can
see from this example the resulting
function isn't one of our nice ones that
begs the question exactly what kind of
functions can you make using these
linear combinations the amazing result
known as the Fourier series says that
actually you can make a lot of different
functions this way let's see an example
to see how this works let's use the
function X cubed on the interval
negative PI to PI X cubed looks like
this we're going to try and approximate
it using our nice functions the Fourier
series tells us what coefficients to use
in our linear combinations we'll start
out by plotting our first approximation
to it using the squiggles with the
biggest wave length okay that looks
really really bad that's okay we'll go
on to linear combinations of two of our
functions hmm that's better I guess okay
let's do a few more as we get towards
the twentieth approximation it actually
looks pretty good okay so our squiggly
functions can approximate a smooth
curved function like X cubed pretty well
but let's give it more of a challenge
with a function that isn't even
continuous you see by the 20th
approximation this looks pretty good
in fact we can prove that as we go to
higher and higher orders we can make
this approximation as good as we want
here are some examples and you can see
that in each of these cases the
approximation works well for them too
the last one is actually a fractal one
of the nastiest types of functions that
there are and yet the Fourier series can
still approximate it I find this
completely mind-boggling why should a
bunch of squiggly lines give a good
approximation to functions that look
nothing like them I have no idea what's
even cooler is that this version of the
Fourier series is merely a special case
of an even more powerful one suppose you
have a complex valued function on the
interval negative L to L by
I mean a function that only takes real
numbers between negative L and L as
inputs but returns complex numbers the
general version of the Fourier series
can even approximate those kind of
functions here's how first we need a new
set of nice functions because our old
ones are all real valued and that won't
do for this this is how we create our
new ones to make the first one take the
two biggest squiggling functions and
multiply one of them by the imaginary
number I and then add them together you
might recognize this as the complex
exponential function do the same thing
with the next two and you'll see that
this is another exponential with a
smaller wavelength and of course we just
repeat this process forever to get the
rest so these are our new nice functions
to approximate a function real or
otherwise with them we do the exact same
thing as we did before we take linear
combinations this version of the Fourier
series will tell us what coefficients to
use the real valued functions the
approximation is exactly the same as if
we did it with the original Flora series
here's an example of a complex function
being approximated so that's what the
fourier series is about approximating
functions but we only thought about
approximating functions on the interval
what about if we want to approximate a
function on the entire real line well
that's where the Fourier transform comes
in and if you're interested in knowing
about that then I will see you in my
next video